Solara and how Solara can simplify
building complex dashboards in in Python
and as you see I put an asteris at
dashboards because Solara is more like a
general web uh framework so you can
build web app in it but most people they
start looking for like a dashboard
solution only to find out later that
they want to build something like larger
or sometimes described as a a data app
but um dashboard is kind of the common
word people
use um
okay so let's introduce myself a bit I
started live as an software engineer um
but then I out of curiosity went into
astrophysics did a PhD and postto there
and this is kind of how
Dolly sees me um so during my post I
created uh two projects one fs and outof
Court data frame and my other work was
on a IPI Viet Library IPI volum um so
these projects led me to become a
freelancer in
2018 and especially the work
on um IPI
viget um and becoming an IPI vidget
maintainer um leted to me becoming
distinguished contributor for Jupiter
and also my work on vaa added
there um so I worked with Pion also on
on facts but really the clients that we
had they drove me towards the the
dashboarding Direction there was a
overwhelming need for for that and a
need to improve that and that led to the
company we have now Vetti co-founded
with Mario and Eric
grow so in this talk I want to describe
shortly why we built pure python
dashboards or web apps um I'll describe
a bit of the problems that we uh we uh
we saw and
solved um I'll describe the solution to
that um I always want to give a bit of a
feeling how it works I'm going to do a
live demo in between and I think after
that it's uh I can better describe what
Solara is and I want to give a few
concrete examples of apps built using
using
Solara so why do we actually build pure
python web dashboard so web uh I don't
think I need to explain everything's web
based now um but why do we do it in in
Python and it's kind of uh it's really
expensive to do separate like front end
and uh backend development uh and
actually the domain expert for instance
a data scientist or a Quant um usually
knows Python and they're actually the
best to translate this into um into a a
dashboard um and also it's very easy to
access all the python libraries that we
uh that we use directly from python
instead of via an API a rest API um so
that makes for faster development and
faster refactoring of your application
instead of having to redesign your whole
rest
API um also very important is uh Team
interchangeability if someone gets sick
and it's your front end person uh the
project can still uh continue if uh if
everybody
uh just needs to know
python uh in summary it's easier faster
and cheaper to uh to make pure python
web dashboards or
apps um so what kind of problems did we
actually see so on the horizontal axis
we have the X um the AIS describing kind
of your dashboard size and we start
often in the like uh on the left a small
app or small dashboard describing
something simple
um but they usually grow and the
dashboard grows in size and it describes
something complex there so there's some
essential complexity in it and that's
fine you're trying to like automate or
solve a complex problem or give insights
into like a complex uh workflow but on
the y- axis we have problems or more
formally incidental or accidental
complexity that could be like your
framework not really working in the way
you want and what we saw is but a lot of
Frameworks that uh once your app grows a
little bit that you um that you have a
lot of these problems and you start
feeling like this grumpy cat uh not
exactly happy and basically dealing with
problems you uh you rather not deal with
so what we wanted is a a solution that
allows you to go further like create a
larger application uh without
accumulating all these uh incidental or
accidental
complexity and hopefully make you feel a
bit more happier like this
C and we believe we've solved that using
solar and that's what I want to talk to
you today about so what other problems
we observe so I'll explicitly mention
vola IP widgets because that's what I uh
developed on but maybe you also
recognize it in the in a different
framework that you use so I talked about
this complexity incidental complexity
and there are few things
why this
happens um it could be that your state
is spread in the UI for instance that
the user logged in is in a checkbox UI
component or it's in multiple components
so it's spread around an imperative API
so you manually need to remove or add UI
elements um and also event handlers you
have to remember like to detach an event
handler otherwise you still trigger some
code um and together you really need to
keep the UI elements in sync with the uh
kind of the state of your application
what it's describing like the filtering
if you're loged in
ETC and all of this is basically um is
that makes it really hard to make your
UI consistent with your uh your state
another thing we noticed a lot which is
a a hard problem is how do you in UI
make it possible to reuse
code uh another thing I want to say much
about that a little bit is but if you're
stuck in the framework you have U maybe
your components are too limited of your
framework how do you get out of this and
all of this this makes you feel like
this cat and we want to like solve that
um on top of that um um not being
developer friendly what we notice with
IP Widget the development cycle kind of
slow restart your kernel refresh your
browser that's not really something you
want to be doing while developing you
wanted this cycle to be
fast um another thing we want modern
python should uh should have type checks
so that is something uh we really want
to have uh and have a test
framework so how do we solve the
complexity so what we actually done is
is take a look at the JavaScript because
they've they've done uh they've gone
through all of these problems and
they're they've buil many many UI so we
taken some inspiration from
react and uh this particular signal for
um library from prea react variant but
the main point is we think AI framework
should be declarative reactive have some
encapsulation or components and a story
for State Management hopefully this will
make you feel like this C so let's talk
about reactive you've probably used an
Excel spread sh uh Excel spreadsheet or
any other spreadsheet like uh um like in
Google you have two cells width um and
length and area is multiplication of
these two you change an element and
everything updates you don't have to
manually go through your spreadsheet to
say this uh this cell needs to be
updated and how does that translate into
to
python um let's imagine you have a
component that shows the first 20 rows
of your data frame um now imagine you
can change it with a slide and you want
to reset it so we have an event handler
that changes this ma row value but you
cannot really observe that this value is
changing unless you're James Powell um
this is really not a a a feature that
that python python has instead you can
uh use a
very pythonic solution is to have a
container around a value in this case we
have a reactive variable Max rows that
you then um write to using the property
value and access using the property
value but this we can Implement um that
our components are
reactive declarative
so what is declarative tell what you
want not how to do it for instance we
have an old kitchen old situation I want
the kitchen to look like this I say say
a builder like make it look like this I
don't describe like first put in the
lights then do the floor then um I'm not
interested in that I want this
solution so how do you do that in a UI
so in a UI you want um um basically UI
to be a function of the data so I
already showed you these reactive
variables so let's imagine we have a
list of messages we can add a message so
we modify the reactive variable or reset
it now we want to react to that so if we
don't have messages we want to show
something special and otherwise we want
to iterate over the messages and show uh
show the message
so what's happening here maybe this is
already very intuitive to you but uh
what's actually happening is all the UI
transitions in this particular example
happen automatically so you don't
manually
create uh the uh the widget underneath
it don't have to manually update it you
don't have to insert it so if I add a
message it automatically insert on the
screen what's
necessary um and you don't have to uh
delete it so if I check
reset and I reset the messages it will
remove all of the infos and replace it
with the warning so that um so that you
don't have to do as much work
manually let's talk about um reusability
and
encapsulation let's imagine we have this
a relatively simple code where we
calculate the unique values create a
figure add a bar plot optionally set a
title and we show it and this could be
code that you're using a lot in your uh
your new
dashboard um so you saw in the previous
slides okay I apparently have to add
this like a component
decorator function name um and give it
arguments great so now I can re uh reuse
this part
chart component in my
application but uh two things like why
how is this like different from a
function and why this capitalization why
is this not a snake case
so here I put another element in it or
making use of another component that
depends on something else now if this
component re-executes Solara will
actually recognize that all the
arguments are the same for bar chart so
it will not re-execute this function it
will actually see okay these are the
same so I'll reuse the previous one um
and um people love this a lot because
for instance a comparison is uh
streamlit would basically reexecute your
whole script while here we only
reexecute the components where uh
arguments have changed or internal state
has
changed okay so we now evolve our app
give it an extra argument so we can
determine what the color of the bar
chart
is um but now imagine that we changed
the color now we re-execute
this function while only the color is
changing and now I get back to why this
is um case like this as if it is a class
uh instead of a function and the reason
is if we reexecute a component there's
actually some memory of the previous
execution there's a lifetime Associated
to this function kind of an implicit
itself if you were talking about an
object and in this case I'll demonstrate
that you using the uh use memo hook
which can hook into the life cycle of
the component and that is
saying the this function should only be
re-executed when the data frame or
column is being changed and now it will
only um execute this function once if
the data frame and column don't
change
um so this shows you like the the the
power of components so let let's go a
little bit further you say well this is
actually too slow it's taking like 2
seconds for my value counts so what what
next um this will block the UI it's not
really user friendly and this uh for
this we have this use thread hook so
that's
basically uh another hook and you see
that the code change is really small and
this allows us to to execute something
in a thread um show the progress uh in a
progress bar and have the whole UI uh
responsive and and this basically this
what's usually pretty complex working
with threads is really encapsulated in
this component so a pretty complex
solution is like fully encapsulated in
this component and and reused many times
throughout the uh your
dashboards um so let's uh uh hope my
lucky slide works again so I want to
give you a little bit of a demo of how
this works in Pro uh in
practice
okay so we start the Solara
server let's refresh
it okay it says no object with the name
page so what Solara wants is a component
with the name
page let this play my data frame okay
what I want to do is I want to take a
look at this category to see if I can
make uh some bar
charts here uh I don't like the casing
here so
I help of co-pilot turn this into tip
occasion and you see I save it and it
automatically refreshes so if I save it
the whole script gets EX
exed
and now um we want to filter by
categories
C we're going to
filter data
frame thank you
pilot I filtered it to war only so
now you want to have a
um take this
one that helps us again so we have have
a nice
label the categories here and you see
that it takes this argument so there's
bir directional communication if it if
the select changes it updates the
value you can see that automatically
rerender so very easy to to set up an
example I showed you this bar chart what
we can do is I already put this in a
module so we can have this bar chart
which actually the
threading now you see that have a nice
visualization so you see it actually
took a long time I put a sleep statement
in there um I prepared some
[Music]
other now we can sh like show a map
maybe we want to reorganize the at bit
bit put this in a side
bar
two columns and not show the data FR
okay and now we have
a app that can handle large data sets
can render and Maps Etc so now you say
okay my colleague is actually uh using a
jupter
notebook well that's great because it's
it's built on top of iPad widget so I
can in the classic notebook Jupiter lab
I can all render this also on collab
this works so I can render it in line
and the sidebar shown here I can make it
render full
screen and what's nice is that I can now
take a look at the reactive
variables and say well actually if I
change it
here
[Music]
so I can read it off in the notebook but
also the other way around so I'm doing
things in
code trigger reender from here so you
can have these like small mini apps that
respond to changes in the
data okay let's
go back to the
talk okay great this worked
[Music]
so what is
solar you've seen a little bit of it so
we have
um two parts so we have the Sara UI
you've seen most of that it's a pure
python web framework to create apps or
dashboards it has a react like like API
so it's inspired on on react but also
have reactive
elements um and together with the
declarative way of writing your app uh
this reduces complex a lot you don't
have to think about like manually
updating um and you can create these
composable reusable UI components having
quite complex Behavior as I shown you
can hook into the life cycle uh work
with threads um but we also because
we're really data oriented have a lot of
components buttons sliders but also for
visualizing data frames um and as I said
we reuse the IPI vidget ecosystem so
there are a lot of third party ipip
vidget libraries that you canot uh
already integrate in your Solara app but
also solving common data challenges um
threading as I demonstrated cross
filtering caching
Etc um and we have a story for uh type
Save State Management so reactive
variables everything's
typed uh that allows you to iterate much
faster without introducing small small
bgs and I didn't mention much about it
but we also have this Solara server I'll
go a bit into detail
later let's describe a little bit how
Solara is
built so on the UI part that you see
here on top that is built on top of a um
react like API called reacton which sit
on top of iPad widget so solarus using
reacton and widget um and the nice
components that you saw are coming from
this third party Library IPI fify which
is the material
design but you can also use these other
IPI
libraries um as I've shown it runs in
the Jupiter notebook also runs on lab or
voila so basically on the whole Jupiter
stack Google
collab but we also have this Solara
server and it's using Starlet fast API
it can use flask um use as a web server
uh still using the same Jupiter
protocols um but this is something we
recommend for for production it has a um
an in process for your kernel it's much
much more efficient for uh for handling
many uh many users and sharing sharing
memory um so just to give you an example
some examples of of um um
to get an idea how you can use salara so
the Solara website itself is written on
Solara and it also has some like larger
demos here's a relatively um simple but
interesting uh example where you can
upload the data sets make a ler
selection and then then download um
download the selections you've done um
demonstrating some of the the uh very
often requested features of uploading
downloading
um a project um started at at Harvard
that was using QT and that we're now
using Solara for to make this uh
available on the
web a very complex way of interacting
with data multiple data
sets um this is an example of where a uh
prototype that was developed in the
jupter notebook um for um for planning
uh District Heating and Cooling
is now turned into a u full full product
that is um the basis of a
startup um we had a solaron a a a
hecaton um that is just finished uh and
one of the groups produced a live
dashboard so these are updated like live
um and we got really inspired uh by the
uh wonderless demo shown at the um open
AI Dev day and we made a reproduction of
that so there are actually on the air
meet in the resourc section we have a
link to that if you want to play with it
or see the
code so Solara open source MIT license
we do regular
releases uh we're growing number of
downloads and stars um we have a Discord
there's also a link in the um uh in the
air meet uh otherwise you can join us
here and and we have a uh we had a
community hecaton withal saraton in
combination with with plumer so we might
do this in the future again so pay
attention if you want to learn Solara
from
us um for adoption it's also really
important that there are some Enterprise
level support and just keep this in I I
won't talk about much about this um so
yeah in summary I think solar really
simplifies building complex
dashboards um it's a modern python web
framework modern in the sense of also
for instance the typing hot reloading um
it pushes the boundary of the size of
apps or dashboards that you uh that you
can build and I think it's really
important to enable domain experts to
write actually very large complex apps
purely in
Python um we think it's really low risk
because we're using proven Technologies
um we have an open source community so
there's quite some help you can get but
you can also get Professional
Services and um at last we want to see
less of this grumpy cat and hopefully
more of this uh this happy cat um I'll
leave you with the resources there are
also resources in the section here on
the uh air meet and if there are
questions feel free to thank you so much
for your yeah thank you so much for for
your talk um I'm Prashant I'm I'm gting
this I have I can see that there are um
few
questions um I will try and show them on
the stage so there are questions how uh
Solaris compares to um streamlet and
then there's another question where it
say how Sol compared to typi um
so that uh yeah I can uh actually I
think my next slide yeah I I have some
comparison of streamlet uh directly I
don't know how much time uh let me just
go through it and um you can read this
yourself later on also the slides are
there generally the the biggest
difference is solar is more towards like
larger applications although you can
also use it like for smaller um
applications Lara has more support for
streamlet like for
callbacks um so you can basically have
like uh interactions with
figures
um and we don't hide CSS and compared to
typi I think typy I don't like writing
my UI in a string um what I want is to
have a type safety in the whole system
and and that is something we we had a
put a lot of effort in uh in a proven
system react is is now a technology 10
year old um it has proven itself um and
I think it's much a much safer bet to uh
reuse a technology that's proven for 10
years instead of
um coming up with your own DSL in a um
in a kind of markdown like
string thank you and there is another
question
um How is is it to study lash boards in
Sol yeah good question so yeah um so one
thing is is it um is it easy uh you can
style it using CSS so that's one thing
so it it is possible um but styling is
always uh always difficult we we usually
uh work with someone that's more
experienced in in um in design but but
they they can fully design like the
Shara Dev website is fully designed by a
designer that that's possible I can do
it myself a little bit as well I have
basic CSS knowledge and some of the
simpler things like colors we
expose um but otherwise we don't try to
wrap another layer around CSS so if you
just ask J GPT like Hey how do I do this
in CSS it should be relatively easy to
uh to apply this to Solara